remain calm i have trained for this
okay
exit the window
here we go make a u-turn if possible
[Music]
right now
are you okay swim for it
i got you oh my gosh
come on
come on
i judge her yeah that's impish oh
are you nuts i judge you and [ __ ] ow ow
okay that is three and you didn't hit
anybody that hard they're not abandoning
the party
hey all right that's enough i'm done
okay
ah
bel schnickel i gotta run out early too
yes
yeah
yes
dwight you have your hand up
ignore him
and now a very special treat a book my
grandmother used to read me when i was a
kid this is a very special story it's
called struul pita
by heinrich hoffman from 1864.
the great tall taylor always comes to
little girls that suck their thumbs are
you listening sasha right and heir they
dream what he's about he takes his great
sharp scissors out and then cuts their
thumbs clean off i'm a pretty normal guy
i do one weird thing
i like to go in the women's room for
number two i've been caught several
times and i have paid dearly
you know i don't have to do paperwork
unless you're actually dating
okay well once this starts it's going to
be moving fast it's going to be hot and
heavy and i don't want a bunch of
bureaucratic red tape wrapped around my
jock you know but i mean
have you talked to her yeah we had a
whole conversation about mondays
do you know her last name yeah toby i'm
gonna tell you her last name tomorrow
because she's gonna be screaming it
tonight she's gonna be screaming her own
last name hey
watch it
good luck gabe
did you have a favorite age
a month
an age or month yeah like a favorite
month like i like
april when i was seven
i've been trying i've been trying to
keep it going
aaron is just
weird how many pillows do you sleep on
at night
well i gotta try it i wouldn't oh come
on what's the heart
hmm
flavor that
penis
the coconut is pretty subtle
why they had coconut i miss original
to cover the mouth a what
a rag a damp rag perhaps
let's remember those procedures what are
the options
that's the wrong way we've already tried
that remember your exit points exit
points people what's now
stay alive i'm getting help pull me up
you're too heavy i only weigh 82 pounds
save bandit
how about 911
[Music]
what do we do use this surge of fear and
adrenaline to sharpen your decision
making okay i am not dying here come on
oh my god what
fire's shooting at us it's a seven
letter word for purse
statue no starts with an h
handbag
thank you
what's a seven-letter word for purse
satchel no starts with an h
handbag
hmm thank you
i'm throwing all right i'm crowning
oh
nobody told me we're gonna have hot dogs
this next award goes somebody really
lights up the office
somebody who i think a lot of us
cannot keep
from checking out
the hottest
in the office award goes to
ryan the 10th
yeah
[Applause]
you sexy things
are being you here you go
[Music]
[Music]
very badly on my foreman grill and i now
need someone to come and bring me into
work
you should floss
fear is what it's all about you cannot
sell
while undergoing fear
you need to vanquish fear
one must wrestle beer
to the ground
you will now wrestle my cousin
you can
you can do it ryan okay
what are you doing
are you really revving up you know that
doesn't work
jackie chan
okay
you are going to learn to be more
professional luke
that's what you're going to do luke
[Music]
okay then
so
where were we
bowling
oh god instead
oh not again
you let go you let go oh you're right i
can't hold on
you two are so evenly matched i don't
know how one of you is gonna get the
upper hand
the important thing to remember jim
we always have what is called the
element of surprise
you